I just remembered
to make a little sheet to pass around
using old media if you happen to have a
pen or a pencil if you want to enter
your name and email in particular I'll
be happy to send you a free ebook about
this lecture and maybe another one I'm a
toss in as well I'm going to give you a
little bit of information about myself
and what my company has done over the
past few years and then launched into a
discussion that I hope will be of
interest to you regarding science
fiction user experience design and to do
that I have to Don my lecture hat so
that I can welcome you as fellow Kyon's
or acai ons or ulcers or Xers
interaction design it's the world of
science fiction and computer human
interaction we at a man a we've been
busy for the past 33 years designing
user interfaces user experiences for
almost all platforms and technologies
I've written 14 or 15 or 16 or edited
rather published books and about I think
this is really 250 articles not 350 I'm
sorry some an intern just counted them
and found that there were only two
hundred and fifty three we have created
ten machine projects combining
information design with persuasion
design in part related to bj fogs
theories of persuasion here at Stanford
and I've been involved in China for
several years with the D tau academy we
have
worked with a lot of corporate large
company clients as well as startups here
are some of the books that I've worked
on the one in the far right is about the
locos visible language system a set of
signs by which you can communicate
anything you can in spoken languages and
it was invented by a friend of mine in
Japan in the 60s this mid year this year
I'll be coming out with a my latest book
which is called mobile persuasion design
from Springer and it will have case
studies of all the Machine projects by
the way James when should we stop too
okay good so here are some of the
machines green machine in the health
machine trying in a mobile app concept
design to help change people's behavior
using persuasion theory and we've also
done the happiness machine in the
marriage machine in the towel Academy in
Shanghai I have been working to try to
create a center for UX innovation mostly
of giving our workshops there this
particular lecture comes from keynote
that I was asked to prepare for the
mentioned computer conference in
chemnitz germany and from that I we
structured the material for this book
which I can send you I've presented this
lecture in various forms around the
world since 2011 I put together a
special issue of UX magazine user
experience magazine published by user
experience professionals association
about science fiction in the future
using attention to science fiction media
to think about user experiences there
was one article examining the kind of
equipment shown in just Star Trek TV and
movie at
sodes I've also published version on
this theme in interactions magazine and
also in UX magazine now the objective is
to introduce you to some issues and
themes trying to understand human
computer interaction or user experience
design and works of science fiction
media which are in film and television
not the movies I'm not treating games
anime etc the world once you start
looking at it just in this topic area so
vast and so deep and and occurring in
most many countries of the world that
it's really a challenge to put together
any kind of survey and this one is is
very ad hoc and very eclectic and very
personal you can first ask yourselves
well who who first wrote about science
fiction some people think some of the
stories in some of the holy writings of
a number of religions are science
fiction there are descriptions in the
Bible the Torah the Old Testament which
are pretty science fictiony beings and
creatures with four faces fiery imagery
of things moving around in space but
there is a reference to Roger Bacon from
hundreds of years ago in which he speaks
about machines flying around with no one
steering them flying machines that can
be constructed and beat the air with
wings like a bird that in fact as many
of you will probably think in your minds
is some of the imagery of Leonardo da
Vinci but that was 200 years later so
this is a very early reference to
unusual
instructions devices and interactions
with that equipment when I grew up as a
small child in omaha nebraska in the
middle of the united states i was amazed
by the things that I saw in Pope science
fiction magazines like galaxies and
Saturn astounding science-fiction etc
sort of the heyday of post-world war two
publications one of the magazines which
I have in my personal collection is
science fiction plus I don't know if any
of you have ever heard of it or seen
this set of images but it was I think a
creation by Hugo Gernsback among others
and featured a lot of stories and
especially amazing illustrations of
robots of rocket ships in general kind
of optimistic post World War two views
of the world of the future with
occasional destructions of the universe
by alien beings and orb rebellious
robots but still overall a rather
enthusiastic and forward-looking vision
I was much influenced by that and with
my late brother we designed such things
as this space helmet made of cardboard
in one light bulb in a toilet paper tube
and I actually designed and built a
rocket ship control panel by which we
could in our imaginations from our
basement fly off to other planets so in
a sense I've been an HCI designer since
about the age of 12 with limited
resources I also drew pictures of future
devices like this one on the left as
well as rocket ships space people in
suits guns ray guns and so on
and I still have a large part of my
collection of science fiction pocket
books paperbacks from that time as well
as comic books which I collected now all
of that gradually went through my
undergraduate life at Princeton studying
physics and math and then Yale's art
school studying graphic design and
through various trips around the world
landed in landed in Berkeley and began
teaching at UC Berkeley computer
graphics courses and in 1992 I first got
the idea and desire to bring together
science fiction writers to come to the
chi conference which I think met in
Monterey California if I remember
correctly I invited Bruce Sterling if
you know him a very funny and clever guy
vernor vinge who used to teach in UC san
diego or belief and several other people
and in 1999 chi remembering the
popularity of that event invited me by
itself to to hold it again in pittsburgh
in the 99 conference in fact I I tried
to get oh my brains forgetting but the
author of Krypton nakhon if you know the
author Stephenson Neal Stephenson to
join us but he couldn't he said because
he was on a book tour and as it turned
out he was in Pittsburgh that very day
talking about his book when we had our
panel opening panel at KY and for that
occasion I invited all of the authors
and myself to wear funny hats so we
would be sort of aliens within the
computer science and cognitive science
community that was well received
and I've been wearing this hat ever
since not every day but on lecture
occasions Bruce Sterling in his original
presentation at Chi i think in 92 when
asked to describe computers of the
future reached into his pocket and said
in the future this is what computer
technology will look like you can fold
it it's flexible it has threads embedded
in it as a battery you can place it over
something and copy that you can see
anything you want with it you can even
blow your nose in it if you want and
after you're done put it back in your
pocket there is a way to create a
taxonomy of human-computer interaction
many people have attempted that and
there are these kinds of issues that I
show you here that could be considered
armed in trying to categorize all the
phenomena all the aspects of development
especially in relation to metaphors
mental models navigation interaction and
appearance likewise in the science
fiction world there is a taxonomy of
sci-fi people have proposed a variety of
ways of categorizing all these in terms
of the story arcs the genres the
particular technology used the view of
society and culture particularly
hardware and software emphasis the
approach to time whether its steampunk
science fiction that mixes a little bit
of 19th century technology with the
worlds of the future and so on imagine
if you will that you take these two
taxonomy xand cross them you now have
hundreds of opportunities for PhD theses
to look at how particular aspects from
the HCI world are thought about or
developed in the various media of
science fiction as they have evolved
over the past
five or six or even a hundred sorry or
ten decades this particular presentation
as I mentioned is somewhat limited and
constrained I'm really just going to
show you some examples from movies for
the most part and a few TV shows to
think about how you could think about
HCI or UX in science fiction media
verbal literature if for the how many of
you are sci-fi fans a fair number you
know to you know and have noticed that
in verbal literature the authors can
describe the inner thoughts of people
much more easily than you can get access
to them in most films in tablet
television programs and they can choose
to describe some aspects of the physical
scene kinds of interaction details etc
but in movies you have to show something
otherwise you have a blank back screen
or green screen and that will won't be
very much of interest to people so it
has been a challenge for movies and TV
they have to show something as you look
at the examples that i'm going to show
you you can think about what are the
assumptions about who's using this
equipment or are these these pieces of
hardware software what sort of control
panels are depicted what sort of
cultural diversity of the user community
is exhibited are there particular
focuses on certain hardware why any
information visualization techniques
that we should note any emphasis
speech or audio versus visual or haptic
displays do these films seem to indicate
any user centered design at all in what
they're showing they didn't actually
have to undergo that process in
producing the kinds of things that
they're showing there they're not
producing products and services for a
real commercial market those are just
some of the aspects that you might think
about or think about these particular
themes what in this movie or TV show
does in fact seemed futuristic or is
there a reference somehow to the present
or past are there any gender role issues
that emerged what roles do men and women
play in these stories and with the
equipment are the views positive about
technology or neutral or negative is the
technology threatening dangerous
fearsome or beneficial and optimistic
and good for Humanity are there any
kinds of culture issues that emerge
because for the most part these films
have grown out of Europe and North
America not China not India not the
Middle East not Africa are there any
sorts of culture or social biases built
in I'm going to begin with a few
historical examples that is older
history some of you may not know all of
these some of you may sit may know some
of them how many of you have seen
metropolis from 1927 a few
most of this is available on YouTube or
somewhere on the web and often in your
local movie theater the earliest science
fiction films as such were created in
France at the end of the 19th century
are sort of the first science-fiction
movie was just a kind of technology gag
in which Pig was fed into a machine and
out came sausage and other pork products
at the other end and that was very
amusing and astonishing to the people
looking at some of the first movies ever
made in 1895 a number of these early
films were made by the Millea brothers
in Paris and in fact their work was a
given a tribute in a recent film let's
see what was it Hugo to show the work of
these early science fiction filmmakers
some of you may have seen a trip to the
moon in which a rocket ship lands and an
image of the moon with some human face
that's quite annoyed getting poked by a
rocket ship or 20,000 Leagues Under the
Sea these were some of the first
attempts to show outlandish or unusual
flying machines circumstances of
movement and high technology here are
some scenes from fritz lang's metropolis
the most expensive silent movie ever
made I have just watched recently a
blended copy
you made from original film of the
complete movie sometimes incomplete
versions are shown it's quite
interesting to see it for one thing the
first robots appear it happens to be a
female robot an evil female robot yes
well I think they as you see here a
machine that's a good point and this is
a movie which is a associate social
political story of capitalists trying to
control production it's a heartwarming
romance between a man and a woman Marie
is the woman who is modelled in this
robot by the magnet and the hero is the
son of this very rich powerful man some
of the control devices which are shown
in this future society are nothing more
than late 19th century dials and gauges
and knobs although there is on the the
rich owner of the production in society
at the time a kind of telephone
connection board with which he can
communicate with people all around the
city or the building or the society
perhaps and his desk is unusually empty
of paper and other items one of the
other important distinctions in this
movie is that a picture I've ideo phone
or a picture phone kind of a connection
is depicted this is 20 years before
television
commercial television so it's really
quite impressive to see this displayed
he communicates in fact with this chief
engineer who's instructed to come carry
out his orders so there are a number of
very important fundamental kinds of
technologies that are displayed in fact
as some people are now beginning to do
some researchers in HCI or mmm I are
just studying the theme of robots in
science-fiction movies in comparison to
the actual performance and
characteristics of automatons and robots
as they have been developed over the
past 50 or more years there are I think
important distinctions in how film
creators created them and described them
and showed them how audiences reacted to
them and the actual constructs in
industrial robots and other
circumstances another example of flat
screen displays was in the 1930s in
Flash Gordon movies if some of you have
seen those this particular one comes
from about 1936 and is not much
different than what you can buy today
from Samsung or what was depicted in
1968 in the movie 2001 people look at it
address it communicate with others there
isn't too much discussion or anything
shown of control devices and details of
interacting with it in general another
early depiction of robots were these
flying machines which were actually kind
of a form of drones that appear in 1941
in mechanical monsters a particular
Superman animation usually I'm not
showing anime
but this is an interesting one because
it was used as an inspiration in sky
captain in the world of tomorrow I don't
know if any of you have seen that one
but it was one of the first movies to be
created on a PC and a lot of the
shooting was with real actors and a
green screen and then all of the other
equipment and scenes were produced by
the I guess director artist I doubt if
any of you know about or have seen
captain video anyone you'd have to be as
old as I am to know about this but in
the 1950s this was one of several
popular TV science fiction program
cereals that appear w I suppose every
week the sets were primitive probably
not too much fancier than my cardboard
and light bulb space helmet in fact at
one point when Captain video with his
copilot was in the rocket ship control
room flying around the universe his
assistant bumped into the control panel
and the entire thing fell over because
it was just a piece of cardboard and
some paper gauges he somewhat
embarrassed lifted it up pushed it back
against the fake wall of the rocket ship
that we could see on the television
screen this was before there were
videotapes to catch and delete such
scenes and had to say to captain video
oh good thing no wires were broken and
they continued with the previous script
dialogue another one was tom Corbett and
his space cadets most of those programs
and certainly movies into a decade later
like
journey to the center of time almost
inevitably exhibited the equipment that
was supposed to suggest high technology
this often included whirling magnetic
disks tape disks many rows of blinking
light bulbs I had some of those on my
rocketship control panel myself and of
course scientists in white jackets and
ties why this person would be in a
regular business suit flying to the
center of earth I don't remember but is
very suspicious that imagery was so
well-known and so often used that it was
used as kind of a gag for the mentioned
computer conference that invited me in
2011 and here are the equivalent of the
IBM 360 mainframes men and women in
white shirts men had ties women often in
the background doing unknown tasks of
clerical or administrative nature
whirling magnetic tapes and blinking
lights that gender role distinction
continues in some science fiction as
elsewhere in the world here's voyage to
the planet of prehistoric women from
1968 a low-budget film that I'm sure
you've never seen featuring men in very
complex and heavily protected suits
flying in their flying machines to a
distant planet that's inhabited only by
women who amazingly don't need any of
this kind of equipment in fact they
don't seem to need very much clothing
for that matter and are able to
communicate telepathically that's
important keep that in mind when we come
to avatar
are many decades later as you can see
from this scene it's filled with men in
white jackets in front of large wall
displays of twirling tapes and blinking
lights this theme of men with machines
and often with armor and arms versus the
gentler females is a theme that has
continued let's look at some more recent
examples but again think about those
issues and the themes that I mentioned
before if you have any comments if
you've seen some of these movies and
have a certain reaction or memory of
them I'll be happy to hear that I'm sure
many of you know this scene immediately
the Star Wars series created by George
Lucas and his colleagues was momentous
in many ways for one thing the rocket
ships were dirty the machinery was rusty
and decrepit in the movies of the past
all of the technology was almost always
gleaming clean brand-new infallible this
stuff failed sometimes sometimes was
broken he also introduced charming
robots CP 0 r2d2 there wasn't so much
HCI innovation to tell you the truth as
far as I feel looking at it he did have
a little mind control of objects he did
have some fancy blinking lights on Darth
Vader's chest piece but for the most
part the
the scenes in rocket ships fighting
space battles which were based as you
may know on George Lucas and his friends
looking carefully at World War two
fighter aircraft fighter war film to
capture the battle scenes much of that
was like then-current cockpits for even
previous generations he did introduce
the lightsaber which was a variation on
sword sword play from centuries earlier
his mastery was in story arcs and
mythological storytelling and the
creation of ver admittedly very
memorable characters so that certainly
is not to detract from his achievements
it just wasn't his seemingly his special
interest to create charming new or
advanced HCI technology excuse me yes he
did have what's her name Princess Leia
with the earmuffs and projected as a
holographic image so that that that
should be mentioned also as one of the
technology items that's worth mentioning
yeah actually in the Terminator series
you see some more technology innovation
certainly like robot vision and
augmented or thank you HCI depictions
which are impressive Star Trek
series supposedly taking place in
twenty-three sixty-six and beyond
created by Gene Roddenberry had a lot of
technology which they introduced almost
all the time there were many devices
there were scenes of people interacting
with them some of them were so well
known unlike the voice communicator that
they were even parodied in other movies
like Galaxy Quest if you happen to know
that lovely film there was another
achievement about the use of the
technology which was a multi gender in
fact a multi alien and human crew
admittedly most of the aliens looked
more or less like human beings with
strange masks on but they were intended
to be of different races different
genders and different species earthly an
extraterrestrial all using this
equipment and that was something of
interest and I think and it is
noteworthy about it in a more recent
release of star trek movie in 2013 the
director JJ Abrams introduces of
wonderful scenes like this one where
someone i think is supposed to be
getting medical treatment to repair of
his wounds or something i can't quite
recall and you can see in the background
there's lots of screens lots of
depictions of complex scientific
displays human-computer interaction
unfortunately we never get close you
never get to see exactly what's going on
which is sort of a pity there are
transparent displays so some of the
information is being shown backwards
which is a modern theme of a lot of
science fiction movies
and of course there is the occasion of a
half-naked woman who suddenly has to be
shown somewhere in the storyline I
forget why she takes her clothes off I'm
sure there was a good reason most of
this is eclipsed by many explosions
action movie sequences etc which
unfortunately I think you've taken over
for a chances to show details of
human-computer interaction or even the
storyline and character development of
the stories the same thing happened in
the game when it rebooted in 2013 most
of it is warrior focused and not HCI
focused here's another famous scene from
the movie which undoubtedly you know
2001 the famous moment when how the
computer running the show reads the lips
of the two astronauts and learns that
they're plotting to kill how turn them
off 2001 was a blockbuster in many ways
it was a creative depiction of advanced
technology combining the minds and
interests of Stanley Kubrick along with
arthur c clarke the author of the
original novel it contained many
innovations like the fact that space is
quiet there are no sounds of rocket
ships flying through space as there were
in previous movies because there's no
air to carry the sound they were
attempting to envision technology 40
years later or 30 years later they did
get some things right and they got some
things magnificently wrong
there were no mobile phones in the world
of 2001 as they thought about it we
didn't imagine that that would come
about people instead we're using
advanced payphone depictions sort of in
order to communicate through AT&T there
are a lot of corporate sponsors many of
the sponsors mentioned at the time not
sponsors but brands mentions the time no
longer even exists there is also I think
one of the first HCI jokes ever
introduced into film in this particular
scene one of the astronauts needs to use
the bathroom but the first thing he has
to do is to read the instruction manual
for how to operate the bathroom it's
quite long one one imagines that he
never did make it in time to the
bathroom here's an executive meeting
that takes place I think on the moon
near the site where they've discovered
the rectangular slab there are no pcs no
mobile phones sitting on the desks it's
kind of a vintage 1950s 60 70 s paper
filled office but but clean and neat and
that in itself is interesting there are
a lot of scientific displays information
visualization which appear throughout
the movie at different times not too
much of it is exceedingly advanced or
unusually well designed it is workman
like I guess I would say and very
typical of the times but at least it is
appearing there and there are scenes of
multi screen displays that appear which
also are given a fair amount of time so
that one can both contemplate the
advanced technology and actually think
about what they might be showing here's
another such scene
of two of the astronauts looking at this
large screen display with multiple
depictions of information some of the
other displays look like cad/cam
drawings of the time in about nineteen
late 1960s and early 70s inside of a i
think a little tiny escape vessel if i
recall correctly or this is the one that
he goes outside maybe to rescue one of
his partners the displays are somewhat
advanced but nothing to write home about
there is possibly a flat display lying
on top of a table where else it's built
into the table in order to give the
person information while they're eating
one of their space meals television
communication or video communication is
shown realistically because of the
tremendous time delays between messages
so in some ways they try to be
scientifically accurate they try to give
a fair amount of attention to details of
HCI display and show how people would
interact with that equipment here's
another fairly iconic image which some
of you will know this is actually from
Tron to Tron Legacy when it first came
out in 1982 and I've just watched
recently on television the original tron
again it was somewhat innovative at the
time because it tried to show to depict
to visualize a world of software
operating systems code in that sense it
was something that had never been done
before
in the end they replay done in 2010 a
lot of the attention was focused on well
phantom beautiful costumes and lots of
motorcycle like action it was sort of an
adventure game it did have lightsabers
of one kind or another a lot of the
equipment focused on this circular disc
of memory and power that when held on
one's back and whenever user interfaces
per se were shown they were either as
the old video games being depicted
depicted from the 60s or something like
the UNIX operating system being shown in
code on screens which was kind of a
charming throwback any other comments
about tron from your own experience have
you seen it robots and to realize that a
personality was actually talking about
programs and where their programs have
person yes yes that's a good point this
is this is a software movie not a
hardware movie that's a good point
please feel free to throw in comments if
you have them this next scene may not be
so well known to you it's one of my
favorite movies yes Brazil Terry Gilliam
who has created many weird and strange
movies delightful in their detailed
backgrounds of things going on this was
if not steampunk it was a strange
combination of not 18th century but late
19th early 21st century dystopian
concoctions of machinery their word
video displays in all the offices but
they were very small black and white
sets in
which lens or something was placed in
front to bang magnify the image so that
if it would have the impression of a
larger screen telephones had numerous
buttons and wires hanging off of them as
did all of the interiors of living
quarters and what was behind the panels
was just a gigantic spaghetti mess of
tubes and ducts on purpose to show a
kind of society that is sort of just was
being held together with band-aids here
is an intrusive little robot camera
inspecting a visitor to the Ministry of
Information I suppose it was here's a
little exoskeleton of a typist busily
typing away what is she typing there's a
close-up of the text that she's typing
she's typing the transliteration of the
screams of people being tortured in the
next room that's her job and here's the
hero just before he eventually succumbs
and goes crazy with some kind of headset
in a large anechoic chamber of some kind
where he's being tortured and or
inspected it's not a very positive view
of Technology a society that has
succumbed to the complexities of this
technology to the extent that people go
out to restaurants where routinely I
suppose terrorists bomb part of the
restaurant in the background and the
waiters quickly bring a screen over so
that those who are still left living can
continue with their meal to not be
disturbed by the gore and destruction
just on the other side unfortunately it
has kind of echoes of some aspects of
life today in some places
nevertheless it was a beautifully
constructed and kind of heartwarming
tale of the young man's fantasy romance
with this woman on the left of his
dreams and here's a memorable
interaction of equipment in human beings
that some of you may recall this is
Arnold Schwarzenegger removing a sensor
from his left nostril which had been
detecting his movements I really don't
know how they managed to do this scene I
don't even want to think about it but
Total Recall by paul verhoeven basing
his movie on just a short story from PK
dick created a lot of memorable HCI
moments there were scenes of large wall
sized x-ray viewing of passengers coming
through security or travelers coming
through security there were scenes of
simulated environments being depicted on
large screens at home so that even if
you didn't have any windows you could
just put up a couple of screens and look
out doors to some environment somewhere
in the world that was quite pleasant
there were body suits and body heads or
artificial heads that could be strapped
in place to disguise one's identity
there were depictions of large brutal
gray metallic equipment that was used to
remove memories and add new memories
into people's lives also in this film
there were there was an example of HCI
humor which I assume was intended this
is a future world very advanced people
are flying to Mars and
back and so on and the hero whose name I
can't remember right now checks into a
hotel in advanced hotel but notice this
screen this is a text screen for the
night early 1980s not likely to be in a
advanced hotel like this with such a
screen but i guess the director decided
he would have a little joke privately
with himself or with the audience oh yes
a virtual athletic exercise partner that
was another one one of the scenes we can
thank you James that that showed high
technology in use by consumers not
rocket ship pilots and that's an
important aspect which you can track in
many of these films because most of them
spend a lot of time in rocket ships
using specialized equipment for
specialized users or operators here's
another sort of consumer technology
innovation which was that phones were
embedded actually with some equipment
right into the hand and you could see
screens and displays by simply placing
them on a glass surface in fact it's a
bit of a bother because this fellow
needs to perform surgery on his wrist in
order to pull out that equipment which
is a little bit gory but was innovative
in terms of handheld devices here's
another iconic image from The Matrix
trilogy by the warshofsky
brothers featuring this kind of falling
type display it was an image like the
twirling magnetic disks and blinking
lights of past decades or the
transparent displays to suggest high
technology it's also the case that well
they added a number of innovations like
using small pills to like Alice in
Wonderland to make you bigger and
smaller to put you into mental states
where you could then participate in the
mass fantasy world that had been created
by the machines which had really taken
over the world most of the scenes as you
can see from these five small images
were often dark black gray blue with
occasional scenes of almost emptiness to
suggest a very powerful contrast of
attempts to kind of clean up this this
world of illusion notice this scene of
this one operator in front of a dozen
displays in the background what's odd
about it is that I think no human being
could actually read any of those
displays from that distance they were
simply there to suggest all powerful
technology being monitored did you have
a question he doesn't read it but ok fit
in well I feel like Red Bull in and for
like whether it was severly yes I do
well there are actually occasions in
fact you can see it here when they are
looking closely at some of the screens
and at the same time you could imagine
that there would be someone who would be
looking for just patterns of change from
a distance but still
I think there's the suggestion that
there's detailed information here which
any in a user-centered design could not
possibly work too well in fact compare
this scene with an actual high-density
display from Bloomberg of six intense
displays of financial information that
were shown at a chi conference about two
years ago I think and are featured in
the ux book this notion of gigantic
displays the information has continued
as a theme in movies because you see it
in oblivion from 2013 if you have seen
that movie this probably may be the
largest tapestry of information I've
ever seen displayed in the movies maybe
someone knows of a larger one I'll
comment more about that in a moment and
by the way we were talking at lunch of
someone reconstructing some dashboard or
James do you remember what we were
talking about for just a moment but this
is someone who is attempted to construct
the Tron dashboard that was shown and to
make it work in some way and that of
course is a theme which you could carry
on in a number of experiments or
projects which is to actually make some
try to make some of the dashboards work
that have been depicted over the decades
almost over a century in science fiction
movies now here is a scene I'll be
interested to see if anyone knows this
one existence very good we have a
sidebar will be expert here this has got
to be one of the weirdest science
fiction movies you may eventually see
because it features
bio-technology flesh-like technology in
ways which you have never seen in almost
every other movie depiction it's a world
about video games in fact embedded 3
deep if I recall correctly in layers of
video game within video games and video
game much of it features biomorphic
technology that looks like skin and
flesh because it is in theory skin and
flesh constructed out of meat which they
grow in laboratories to contain all the
necessary apparatus there is like in
matrix and like not Gibbons proposed in
in the first cyberpunk science-fiction
direct connection to the spinal column
in fact there are scenes of drilling the
holes and pushing little things into the
hole in order to get stuff into the
nervous system one of the more memorable
moments of technology is when the hero i
believe is having a meal at a restaurant
is served some food notices the bones
and some teeth of whatever he was eating
left on the plate picks up some of the
pieces starts to move them around pushes
some of the bone things together and
creates a pistol puts in some of the
teeth and shoots and kills the waiter
highly unusual
there are also moments of humor when a
sort of humor or sarcastic or comical
notes when a catalogue for body parts is
shown and you can if you stop the movie
you can read what they created for what
you could order for your for your own
body or game here in the laboratory the
this is bloody technology that they're
putting together here's a one particular
scene when they're pushing forget what
the purpose of this little blobby Plato
like thing was that they're pushing into
the central nervous system but they do
here he's assembling his pistol you play
with biomorphic command and control
devices there is a headpiece that people
put on to I believe get connected into
the games or levels of the game world so
this has quite a lot of creative
technology much of it quite different
from anything that you've seen in Star
Wars or captain video or any of the
other movies let's take a look again at
these themes think again about what we
shown well we consider more recent
movies like Minority Report this again
as a PK dick short story turned into a
movie he was a incredibly powerful or
has had an incredibly powerful influence
in his short stories Steven Spielberg
took this put Tom Cruise in it and had
Tom wave his hands and thus was born all
of the PR and interest in hand gestures
for human-computer interaction which was
good in some ways although not very
practical from the human factors point
of view exceedingly tiring if you had to
do that for more than a few minutes but
they did show virtual avatars
a lot of transparent displays that you
could see backwards a lot of advanced
technology mote most of the hand waving
was just two seemingly move photos
around and not very complex interactions
at that but very very influential let's
say in discussions of HCI and it wasn't
long before Samsung and others were
showing in fact you can such transparent
displays as these where you could look
into the room next door or anything else
that you wanted to depict if you want a
privacy you could lower virtual blinds
or have scenes appear as necessary in
the displays here's another scene from a
movie which possibly you've viewed if
you don't have enough hands to carry out
the task you can simply graft on to more
to the bottom of your feet or your legs
rather as this person does in the movie
does anyone know the movie thank you
shown again not too recently they're
quite recently on TV about a post virus
world after 2011 by a woman director one
of the few women directors of these
films it features a number of HCI
innovations like passing information
through a little capsule or a pill
that's passed from one mouth to another
because they don't want anyone else to
capture the information skin displays
you click your hands on your forearm and
suddenly a map is depicted to guide you
through a building one of the heroines
eyeballs is replaced by a camera which
she kind of rolls into place by tipping
back her head is she goes into a dream
state to contact headquarters and others
of her secret group one other charming
device created was a set of rolling
drones I guess you could call them
they're not flying but they're little
marble things that she carries with her
throws on the floor they run off and
inspect the environment I guess report
back to her or can assemble as they do
in the movie in order to explode and
knock out part of a wall what was
charming about is that she calls them to
attention by hustling for them and they
all hear her and come to her rescue her
attention here is an information
visualization display which you may know
or remember from probably wouldn't
remember it ultraviolet which you may
have seen this is a guide to moving
around in the building there are
transparent displays there are paper
phones which are used once and thrown
away from a vending machine I think
interestingly this world of the
not-too-distant future of 2078 has
writing which we can no longer read very
easily in a surviving core of humanity
following some worldwide disease or
plague if I recall correctly but it's
interesting that the the writing system
at the time has so changed and in let's
say sixty years that we can no longer
read this text maybe you know this one
this is a science fiction comedy thank
you idiocracy by my judge I guess we
could expect that of him this is an
enormously funny and depressing view of
the future in which everyone through
poor education for the most part except
of course currently people here has so
dumbed down society that an ordinary guy
in the army who is put into a state
suspended animation along with a
prostitute and forgotten for 500 years
finally wakes up and discovers he is the
smartest man on earth because everyone
else is so uneducated simply stupid the
President of the United States depicted
here controls the Congress with
automatic rifle at meetings most of the
large screen displays are basically sex
and stupidity comedy no one can spell
any more so even a medical assistant in
a hospital has to use little pictograms
to try to diagnose what might be wrong
with the hero when he comes to complain
about something and all the newscasters
are naked on the evening news avatar you
probably know quite well from James
Cameron this is again a clash of men and
machines against the gentler folks
somewhat matriarchal in nature it's
certainly the women can communicate with
each other with animals with trees with
the central tree of feeling and
knowledge and it's a battle to the death
assisted by these transparent screens
this is rath ova which is avatar spelled
backwards because we see it on the
screen backwards looking through the
screen now this this particular
technique of display as has a long
history Leonardo da Vinci in painting
the the Last Supper you probably an
image springs to your mind if you
studied it in art history it's a long
table with the Apostles at the side and
Jesus in the center that isn't the way
banquets took place at that at the time
that it's supposed to be they were you
shaped tables but Leonardo faced with a
room in which he had to depict all this
and and the scene that he wanted to show
broke apart the standard way in which
people ate put them all in a straight
line why because we could all now see
their faces which was
very useful for his storytelling same
thing here the camera can look right
through these screens you can see the
emotions of the actors we're running out
of time so i'll quickly sum up here's
district nine which depicts a space
aliens over Johannesburg South Africa
there are scenes in here if you ever go
to see it please do there's a three
about a three minute depiction of hand
manipulation by an alien which is ten
times more beautiful and complex that
anything that Tom Cruise did in Minority
Report it's a wonderful depiction of
human-computer interaction techniques
you may know this one prometheus by
ridley scott who just produced Exodus
gods and kings in this case he wanted to
use real equipment and not a lot of CGI
he has controls which are boba sea and
and weird-looking as probably they would
be if from an alien civilization if we
were to find them amazingly this human
sized Android fits into the seats is
able to read the writing and to
manipulate the controls they also show
three-dimensional depictions of a sort
of like drone cameras discovering what
the layout of this special spaces that
they've discovered and lots of Spanish
essentially brute blue screen displays
for me oblivion by joseph kosinski has a
fair amount of HCI depictions which i
urge you to take a look at wraparound
displays Pacific Rim has followed a
theme in current movies of of trying to
decorate the human body with
exoskeletons and they're quite a number
of lovely scenes of these amazing
computer graphics some of it quite
fantastical and hard to believe can show
anything useful in information along
with flying numbers that go up and down
the screen for no
reason battlestar galactica is a US
television series redesigned from the
original lots of the screens look more
typical of the past edge of tomorrow
with the Tom Cruise again exoskeletons
inspired by Japanese graphic novel it's
not only Hollywood that has produced
interesting and strange displays of
future technology some of you may know
that Apple did in the knowledge
navigator from 1992 depicting a foldable
display picture of Steve Jobs a
caricature and natural language
technology that many people poo-pooed
saying this couldn't be accomplished for
20 years and it's true it took 20 years
to create Siri which now operates AT&T
did the same thing the Department of
Defense created augmented cognition and
had headsets which could change could
sense when the brain was being
overloaded in a particular channel and
changed the medium of display most of
what I've shown you has come from Europe
and North America but India China and
Japan have also produced science fiction
you can go to if nothing else websites
to list all of this from Wikipedia i
don't have images of any of these china
has done the same thing here's one of
the first major science fiction movies
in china death ray on coral island from
1980 with people in white coats and
typical clean displays of a generation
earlier there are some new science
fiction authors coming about like this
one creating the three-body problem
which I I think will find its way into
films if you're talking just about
Japanese science fiction oh my goodness
is there a lot to choose from I don't
have time to to even begin to show you
example so some closing thoughts these
HCI movies are ways to think about doing
personas and use scenarios
you can do studies of what people seem
to find acceptable useful and
interesting you can use them as a gauge
of what people thought was acceptable or
understandable in terms of future
technology there's a lot to look at I
hope you will be inspired to look
further thank you for your time sorry
we've run out officially of time for
questions I take it people have to go if
you want to ask a question send me an
email and thank you for your address
here
you